a pot of narwhals comes bobbing into a
small bay created by a crack in Arctic
ice
narwhals are unique species of whale why
unique because narwhals have a horn that
can grow as long as nine feet it looks
kind of like a tusks and it's actually
an overgrown tube that grows through a
hole in the narwhals upper lip no one
knows why they have this tusks they use
it for jousting but it doesn't seem to
serve any evolutionary purpose the
narwhals often travel in small numbers
but today with a rumor of Arctic cod
under these waters the narwhal as Cod
might swell to over a hundred but
they're taking a big risk the ice is
still shifting here and they could get
hemmed in in fact that's exactly what
happens without warning their access to
the open sea closes off the narwhals are
trapped here you can get a good look at
that tusk a tusk that was sold by
hunters centuries ago as a unicorn
for ten times its weight in gold the
entire pod has to Bob up in this tiny
pool of water if the hole closed over
they'd have to swim under the ice until
they found air
it's possible they wouldn't before the
lack of oxigen children
then as suddenly as it closed the ice
moves again clearing away out of this
trap and they're free free to resume
their hunts for shrimp fish and squid
free to jost free to do well whatever
else they do with that mysterious tusk